alex is with us Alex's in Wisconsin hi
Alex how are you not too bad Dave I want
to thank you first off because I'm
pretty sure my wife is praising God that
I found you she tried to get me to read
your book and I actually read it last
weekend and listened to the audiobook
version as well so and I listened to
your show every day now because it's
absolutely positive so it's good for the
whole marriage and morale and the
relationship issue that we're having is
we have a morale question we have about
70 grand and consumer debt like credit
cards and stupid little things like that
together we have a combined a household
of 110 and or possibly 120 my wife's
wage fluctuates and before I discovered
you I made a really dumb mistake and got
a VA home loan and actually put an offer
in on a house with an earnest offer so
the question comes down to is what's the
moral correct answer because we feel
like we're obligated morally to actually
purchase the house rather than take the
thousand dollar hit and back out and
actually continue baby step two that's
where we're struggling right now so how
hot is the market that you are in it's
it's very interesting houses are going
pretty quick how hard a for the seller
to resell um honestly I don't think it
would be that hard I mean everything's
getting if you if you were to we used
red fin to fine it in the first place
and they already had two other offers
before us so I mean the market is hot
according to the VA according to
everybody in this area so why don't you
call the seller and tell them what
you're facing I've never actually
thought of that that actually sounds
like a really good idea and just say you
know I would I would beg you for mercy
and let me out of this deal but I and
and most people in our culture today
would just walk away but I feel like
I've made a contra
with you and I need to honor the
contract but I'm asking you to release
me from it I'd be happy to let you keep
my thousand dollars and I think you can
resell the house and make more on it
anyway and I see if they see if they'll
give us so you know we're a young family
we got $70,000 in debt we've been off
more than we can chew we've woke up and
realized this it's not simple cold feet
it's mathematics we really are in a mess
here and and yet we've we've made we've
given our word and so we're asking your
mercy to let us go to release us and if
they let you go there's nothing immoral
about that obviously he might be so
shocked that someone had that much and
integrity and honor that they would just
let you go
it could happen they may not they may
not but the given especially given that
they can resell it yeah exactly and I
think that that is the best advice I've
heard all day on it because I've asked a
couple other people and oddly enough I
can't everyone knows about to even my
boss knows about you because I told him
my plan to pay off something he's like
oh you're doing s to you I'm like no
we've never done that I've I've just
read the book like crazy that everybody
I know knows you but I've never heard of
you until literally two weeks ago it was
my mind we're glad you're here we're
glad you're here it's all good and
you're gonna go through Financial Peace
University is my guest because you're a
man of honor and I appreciate you
struggling with keeping your word that's
such an unusual and wonderful thing
thank you sir so you hold on and we're
gonna sign you up for Financial Peace
University the blessings have already
started flowing see that's how that
works and you call that guy and if he's
an old guy like me he'll probably let
you out just because he'll think this is
cute if he's a young character he may
hold you to the deal and if he does do
the deal yeah it'll be it'll be okay
you'll survive it's not gonna it's not
gonna bankrupt you it's just not a smart
wise thing to do is you have realized so
but following through on your word is
always the best thing to do even when it
leaves you with an
ouchy because the long-term ouchies of
no integrity are much higher thanks for
calling in in all the real estate agents
in America just said Amen someone that
signs a contract to buy a house actually
ought to keep their words that are just
willy-nilly walking away people walk
away from contracts like it's nothing
now much less walk away from keeping
their with a simple handshake I mean
it's it's when I got the real estate
business in 1978 if you broke a contract
we would sue your but because we believe
back in the Dark Ages that if you gave
your word you should keep it but now
people just sign up so there's a god
forbid my feelings would be hurt you
know and so you know it's just like geez
man so I love guys like that right there
what a stud that's very cool